okay hi everyone welcome to another wolf
and language design review we are
talking about ontology
and uh hierarchical entities
so Tony where do we start here
so yeah that's basically the agenda from
LA time but updated with two new
sections one is an updated
taxonomy of types yeah with our current
terminology and then some clarification
on the new syntax or what does not
change
so the taxonomy of types is about you
know the
existing entity types that we have that
we now call entity Source types below
them specializations and optionally
property source
okay so hold on let's give an example of
this
so taxonomic species
is an entity Source type is that correct
yes
as you carry out also an entity Source
type or is that I don't understand that
the the root of the tree
explain this tree yeah so taxonomics PCS
SDI entity Source type and below that
all of them are type specializations
okay
why is it necessary to distinguish those
two things the roots of the tree and the
rest of the tree The Entity Source type
is what appears in the first argument of
entity and only the entity Source type
ever
sorry say that again I got distracted by
something only the entity Source type
ever appears in the first argument of
entity that's right
I see that's what we call it entity
Source type while the specialized types
they can appear in property first
arguments and entity
there has to be UNIF unification of the
entity name across all entity
specializations
that is this leaf
down here somewhat deep down you know
when by the time you get the leaf for
individual entity all those leaves
must be distinct independent of their
paths
does that make sense
if the if the underlying structure is
just an entity
with which has first argument entry
Source type second argument entity name
that means the names have to be unique
across all branches of the entity
specializations
for a given entity Source type
yes
okay
I mean Michael Allen everybody desirable
okay fine fine I'm just checking yeah
that's an implication
okay
um
all right
so
one thing is these are yellow
but they didn't land yet so to speak I
mean they didn't go too down to an
entity they're still entity what are
these things
entity types so it's a proposal to have
a new
object an entity type okay I claim it
shouldn't be quite yellow
yes so that's just an idea for it
type setting but I like to touch
Advantage it should be quite yellow it
should be some some slightly different
color
possibly
I think so why not I think so too so
just really make sure yeah
but I think you know like that looks
just like an entity here except it
doesn't have an energy type
yeah would it have a stronger or weaker
color than entities
I would say weaker it's kind of like not
really the goods it's really like still
the infrastructure
um
okay
this is just a naming I mean the fact
that those are in a weird font is
unfortunate but irrelevant
that's cool
okay
so if I look at one of these in input
form for example
okay so that's what we agreed before
that it's an arrow sequence is that
correct yes
if I go down to this one here
it'll be multiple arrows
yeah ideally you would see that in the
tooltip yes
okay
all right
now I couldn't say entity here it would
re-entity class always
yes
because we use entity class when we want
to represent a list of entities instead
of an aggregate entity
I see
Mr also think it's called yeah I think
it's correct too
I mean the one exception that we have
for this is food because then we want to
average but typically for species you
don't want to average
you don't have an abstract metal image
of a mammal with a certain sites at Fair
weight
that was pretty cool what just happened
there
wow
okay so if I wanted to go down to
uh let's say bird here can I do that
and by the way we should have
autocompletes that that show you what
you can do at this level yep and we
don't have a type below animal at the
moment as you can see from the type
graph
[Music]
I see
what was the why was this faster what
was loading previously
I mean this wasn't going directly to the
server it wasn't going to the world from
alpha so this was some kind of local
thing
depending on your cash State you might
need some metadata first and this is
going to improve you know
but yeah
I think even in the second call there
was a server call but just one well in
the first time animal doing here
that is a sub label which is independent
of ontologies but the domain developer
can choose those sub labels if
they wish to
so it's a different feature
okay I mean I think they could go a bit
smaller and a bit lighter
yes we already have a report for that
does it care that the dodo is extinct
no I'm sorry
it's taken care of
what's that girl you mean you killed the
last Dodo or something what no there's
this uh
oh they're bringing it back yeah
okay okay okay okay okay okay that's
what you mean by a couple more weeks
yeah okay all right fine
um
really dodos with that big
who knew
um
okay
uh
let's keep going
now why doesn't that say for an animal
because it isn't an animal it's a bird
in some sense although that's a type of
animal but
yeah it could be that uh and um that
this needs re-evaluation
it might be but otherwise it's a data
quiz yeah
I don't understand why these are Brands
these ones don't
yeah
okay okay no problem
entity type list
I see that's all the
sub places where that occurs
yes
going up the tree
um
what the hell is that sorry that that
that's both that's rather ugly what does
that mean what is that
there seems to be the new auto
completion
I think this is the new project from
neurologist
okay not fun it's um
so Ben maybe can just take a screenshot
and just comment but that's not
uh correct fonts I'm sure they know that
yeah and entity type is still not
officially exposed yeah waiting for this
review basically that's that that's why
there's no Auto completion I see
okay
all right what's this
so here you can show look at the
tooltips of the first and the last
properties and you just see that the
type argument is different
I see that so that's a property only
available
in that Branch yes
I see and the fact that I mean this is
the story of you know the astronaut
who's also a painter
that you could have
because there's a unique name that
refers to the entity even from the fact
that it's a person
you can then have the property
has the you know painter notable
artworks
you know you can have
person Arrow painter comma notable
artworks person Arrow astronaut comma
missions or something
but it's the same underlying entity is
that correct yes because the entity is
uniquified across the
um Source what did you call it the
entity
um
it's a good sign that I can recreate
that name without remembering what it
was
suggests it's the right name
okay
so I see so this is
I don't quite understand this what what
did this mean by entity type name
oh those are the things which are pure
taxonomic species
as opposed to
specifically identified as animals is
that right
yes and it also shows that there are no
special properties for eukaryote
right right I get it
there could be but there aren't
correct
okay what's this
one is showing that when you go down in
the hierarchy to the specializations you
get more properties which is the
opposite of when you go down for the
entity count yeah you get less and less
entities when you go down
right because you're getting right but a
single entity could be in multiple
places on this tree correct yes
what this means
okay all right
that's very weird why does it do that
I mean that's an entity type why is it
parenthesizing anything after it
is what I'm saying I don't even think
that animal thing is doing us much good
there
why is it there
that would be for species developers
okay do we have any of those people here
so this is uh basically showing all the
uh Kingdom or super Kingdom of the war
uh Texas available so for eukaryotes uh
it belongs to uh eukaryotes super
Kingdom so it's showing in the sub-level
showing the sub-level eukaryotes are due
to
I think it looks kind of silly I mean in
other words down here
I don't really think I mean I I don't
know why we put the brand animal here
for any of these I mean okay for a strix
barrier I wouldn't necessarily know what
it was I was going to say it looks silly
for the for the few thousands one knows
it looks foreign
if it's a common name if it's a non- not
a you know a linnaean binomialish name I
would say drop the animal
and also snakes for an animal just
doesn't make sense
right
it will be puran animals plural
am I making sense
and even the scurrier die whatever they
are are plural animals
do you see what I'm saying yeah
so I just a little bit more curation is
needed for that
I mean
but again
for all things which aren't scientific
names I say you drop the word animal
but radio moment with respect to the
plural like in an output form of a
normal entity we also don't use it seems
to me very similar
well give me an example
control equal Einstein and then
click into the result so it becomes
output
input sorry
here yeah
what's your point
I thought you just said it should be
animals and not animal no no I'm saying
in the case of snakes plural it should
be animals plural
right for bald eagle it should be animal
singular
for snakes it's many animals many types
of animals or should the label be snake
no because it's a no no that would be
super confusing
look we know if you're down at the level
of a species
right it's a single thing the point of
this is it's not a species
right if I take that and I don't know
what it is what is it it's a um
so it's a
I don't understand this this is crazy
that's not a species it's a what is it a
family or something
I think snakes and lizards are part of
squamata which is a phylum right
am I making sense this is not a freaking
this is not a species
but but
look in the past we've had no choice but
to pretend that you know mammals are a
species but now we can do better
this is not a species
I mean to me
nobody says it's a species it is an
entity under taxonomic species
okay fine but then I'm just saying
in its common form whatever it is
whatever this form is don't use a
singular if it's not a species I see
I see I see I see what you're saying
use plural if it's higher up a dialogue
here exactly okay I get it I get it so
like this one is presumably
down at the bottom of the hierarchy it
should just be animal if we're going to
use the term animal yeah I I I get it
and that should be a plural
that makes sense yeah
um
okay now what what are you but in that
case to be a bit more specific like
animal field or something like that I
don't know what
so animal family or
to be a bit more specific it would be
nice if we if we gave the phylum you
know the level that it's at phylum
family whatever it is yeah
I mean even if we just said phylum the
without saying animal because I think
the animal part is going to get fairly
silly many people you know animals is an
everyday term
I mean Animalia is a scientific term but
by the time you say
that you know a worm is an animal most
people would think that was weird
I don't know what do you think I mean
the one possibility is we label the
hierarchy level here
this is kind of silly because this is
probably some you know microscopic
uh you know protozoan-like thing
and calling as an animal seems silly
am I making sense
no no I think it's a big object
s of Arya
yeah I think so oh gosh okay fine
so it must be something subsequentially
bigger than the object yeah yes yes yes
yes yes okay I'm I'm truly corrected
there okay
okay
but
the question of whether we should say
the level here is not obvious to me what
do other people think
okay so for this one I created saying
volume would be not bad but for other
domains where there aren't technical
terms for the intermediate entity levels
the name like us pronoun would be the
only option because we don't have
like I agree by profession is title or
something like this yeah we also don't
have categories I mean we I mean we
might have Mercury astronauts or
something yeah
but then we don't have to say Mercury
astronauts paren astronauts
well I don't have a strong feeling but
it clearly cannot be singular yeah okay
great okay all right let's keep going
what were you demoing here
so those were basically some examples of
seeing the ontology features and use
well how is how do I see an ontology
yeah behind the control equality there's
an interpretation that
maybe if you click into and hit enter
if it's gonna work
because I don't think I'm connected to
the yeah
I'm not connected to the right right
well from Alpha
okay so you can tell me what that says I
mean
or or are you going to tell me to change
my preferences what should I do at least
in a few examples below you can see the
actual query
well
under entity classes heaviest whale for
instance
okay
so a maximum recorded weight could apply
to anything
but if it was thin size it would be
likely to be entity property taxonomic
species Arrow
something that ends in fish and then fin
size
yes this is pretty nice it's pretty nice
I think
okay so plant
yeah good so that applies to animals it
doesn't apply to plants plants don't
have a maximum speed
except for the tree I'm seeing walking
across the
lower light
that's cool how do we have this data
do we have that data in any serious way
species
good stuff
I see
fine so these are generic conservation
status and biome are generic
I mean that's probably generic as well I
would like to see some ones that aren't
generic
well that one was not generic
this is looking nice
except for the fact that this animal
thing just seems completely unnecessary
I don't know at least chub do we need
the perenna animal there
no I would not know what it is either
well maybe we just have to make the
smaller and grayer and that'll be okay
but what's the difference between that
and when I say New York City or
something
and I see this city thing what's the
difference between the city lower case
you know you got what I'm saying but so
if you copy one of those animals and use
it as input forms you will also see the
type
foreign
what is the type if if you evaluate the
input form in place then you'll see the
type label
instead of the paren animal yeah that's
a buck now so wait a minute what do you
mean it's a bug should I see the animal
as well as the type yes yes
in some sense the sub label is
considered a part of the label I I
understand I got it I'm not sure that's
right I think it's going to get way too
long and in this case you're only
showing
you know I don't understand why you're
not showing a sub case here if this is
oh I see because the entity itself only
you know is only based on
the
uh
it's a taxonomic species we don't know
more about it
yeah I understand and we might have to
enumerate many sub or specializations if
you want to show more types
no I understand I understand well no
that yes we might there might be in many
specializations it might be so and so is
both an astronaut and a painter
and so we only want to show that they're
a person here yes
okay but this business about saying for
an animal okay we've just got to make
this graphically lighter okay lighter
and smaller yeah
and then we should just see a couple of
examples of when that is combined with
this thing here to make sure it's not
stupid looking
makes sense yeah yes
okay I think in general I see the The
annotation that something isn't animal I
would find useful mostly for output
because for input you would copy paste
and you know what you had yeah I agree I
agree with that I agree with that so
what this is doing is not really a bug
you know this thing here that in the
input well I don't know what this is but
this is output or input or I'm confused
but I agree with you we don't need an
input
because most people don't type it well
actually no wait a minute Michael
Michael that's not right because in
control equals right what's it going to
turn into you're going to have to see
control equals I thought it was a movie
oh actually it came out as an animal
so I think historically we introduced
sub labels for cases where we have a lot
of data I remember yeah and entities of
the same type whose label is the same
and we want some indication of what this
entity is so that's not the case of the
tri-color shark minnow
there's only one tri-color SharkMan that
well presumably once and I mean you know
you know what I'm saying there's only
that is not we do not need it for this
ambiguation here
all right so it's more for explanation
yes
because these names are obscure and
because we think
okay look I just don't buy this I think
knowing
that a Watercress data is a taxonomic
species whether it's a fish a bird a
protozoan I don't care at this level
I've got some orientation here
I mean you don't have to have it if you
don't like it we don't I don't think we
need it I don't think we need it I think
I think we don't need it I mean
especially because this guy's silly I
mean you know tilapia is an animal well
it's not to fish well that's a part of
Animalia but well it's not really an
animal it's a fish type thing
see what I'm saying it's like there
would be say Tilapia as a food which you
couldn't if you don't I know I know but
if it says taxonomic species it isn't
the food that's correct
I think these are just confusing okay
um
I mean that's my current position okay I
you know we need to see more examples
that I might might have to change my
mind but I I think we should switch it
off for now okay this is an entity store
yeah so so that's a proposal for how
users can define specialized types of
their own types
parallel to where they Define entities
and entity classes they can Define new
entity types at the same level
Okay so
okay but to wait a minute okay so the
entities have been given canonical names
above and now we're referencing these
canonically named entities within the
entity type hierarchy correct
[Music]
and otherwise we would just give
if it wasn't for the entity types
we would just say that Anna has property
blah blah blah well how would we do that
oh they're right here right that that's
the top level that's the independent of
subcacing of subtyping properties
yes
okay don't we have a way of declaring
the
properties associated with the given
entity type
yes we can explicitly list the
properties and even give them metadata
like a label okay so we need a mechanism
for doing that for the case of of sub
type that is basically the same it just
nests okay all right I'm just not seeing
that right here but yeah yeah so so
where it says entities at the same level
you can always say properties goes to
and then Define what birth state is
about and you can do that at a lower
level too by saying something like
uh
uh person Arrow birth date a person
Arrow painter Arrow birth date is that
correct well just below entities where
the association ends you would say
properties goes to no and then say birth
date
in debt as in an association
goes to Association and one of the keys
is first date
okay but how does that specify that
that's a property of a sub
entity type in this case you specified
at the level of person yeah if you want
it at a level of musician yeah or into
the musician Association
oh I see I got it I got it I got it I
got it I got it you're just listening
for this type
just like realistic but this type we
listed it's entities we list its
properties for this subtype we listen to
these realistic properties yes we repeat
the syntax yeah it makes sense
okay
and there's also if we have subtypes
there's a proposal to show the graph
in that
yes
what do we show in the entity store
otherwise
um the graph is just not there if it
were just a few dots unconnected
that that can be improved because we we
have for the databases project a better
type setting and at some point we want
to do that it's a good general idea
yeah
okay what else do we have to figure out
here
well so we could review The Entity type
reference reference page the proposed
one
of the time to that
um
I we may not be able to do that here
uh
I should sound so complicated I mean
people need to understand this but
yeah okay I mean that doesn't look bad
so the question this could go many many
levels right so you have to do a dot dot
dot here
yes
um so so there's a comment in the
details section there's no not good
enough not good enough
you should just say Arrow
child one Arrow child two Arrow dot dot
dot okay
[Music]
um
yeah it looks reasonable actually
just reasonable just fine
child's type of tree
what's the difference in child type tree
and entity type tree
yeah so entity type 3 gives the same
thing as editor graph just a three part
three part of it while the child tribe 3
was meant to have the type where you
started with as root
I'm sorry why isn't entity type tree the
thing where this type you started with
is the other route we could not do it
like that yes
it's super confusing if you say tree it
better be a tree
it's always a tree the question is where
the root is yeah
so if you say let's say listen listen I
mean if you say graph it is in terms of
our built-in
you know structures it is a graph if you
say tree it better be a tree a green a
tree yes that's two in both cases so the
question is if you say animal yeah do
you want just one leaf tree or do you
want the three starting at species
so those are the two cases that we have
with native tree and entity or Childtime
tree
well so child type 3 just makes the one
with with animal yes
so you're saying given
given an entity type
do you show it starting from the overall
route from its entity Source type or do
you show it going down from the type
that we have right that we have before
us right now correct
I would call that something like
um rooted entity type tree for the case
where it goes all the way up to the top
okay
or maybe have the word Source in it
Michael anybody else was about complete
or fall
yeah
that seems reasonable to me
I mean I think entity type 3
going the default should be the one
going down I would think
even though it usually won't be terribly
exciting
um
what about
actually there's an obvious thing one of
them is called entity type tree and the
other is called entity Source type tree
yes
um
yeah because we've got entity Source
type here and just entity Source type
treat the tree that hangs below that
yes I like that yep
okay let's have a quick look at this
optional topic and then we wrap
um yeah sorry we move entity type to the
system and experimental okay
looks good to me I'm looking this is
looking really nice I mean it's quite
simple now which is always good
right so the upside topic is well
um shall we embed labels into entities
the reason is you might give a notebook
to someone else they vary identities and
need to display them they need the
labels and the other person receiving a
notebook might not have the label cache
yeah I I think it's horrifying that we
don't have the label cache
and the label cache will never be very
big
I think I think there was a small
difference this was not what Tony asked
okay but yeah it's it's another idea to
on first use of any entities get a cache
of all labels of all entities that's the
other alternative no no no no what I'm
saying is
this crazy business about how fetching
you know we've got the entity but
fetching how to typeset it is a whole
nother
you know palava that's bad
they could just use the canonical name
or no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no look look right now I've
never understood why it is the case that
when you have given you ask for entity
list you retrieve a bunch of entities
okay then there is a second delay
associated with typesetting those
entities
what is that second delay yeah that
delay should not be there because when
the entities are retrieved
the labels are coming with the result
okay is that new not that has been like
this forever modulum box but it should
work at all then there's a bug okay so
what are you now proposing what what's
different from the labels on with the
entities yeah I'm proposing that the
labels are placed into the entity that
means a entity is self-contained to
typeset without any external influence
it's the design of external identifiers
you mean to have a metadata option in
the entity yes
I don't like it I don't like it because
people need to be able to manipulate the
stuff they need to be able to do
comparisons I don't like it
I think having that stuff there as a
hidden cache is a fine idea having it be
something that messes up the canonical
form of the entities is a really bad
idea
so regarding comparison we already allow
aliases in the second argument of entity
now so you'll never know until
normalization uh but this is exotic
not the norm
this is a mistake we should make this
happen behind the scenes
okay
you know with a cache maybe an sqlite
cash I don't know what kind of cash it
is but some some you know some cash
where you can quickly look this up but
not where it's actually visible here
okay yes so so the cache is in the works
yes
okay fine
all right anything else to discuss here
that's it for my site
okay this looks really nice really nice
I mean I I you know
and when do we get to see species in all
its Glory so to speak
very soon okay
like week or so or
two releases yeah two more releases yes
that's right
but so we expected in thirteen three
yes I think so I mean it's it's the
factory independent modular the ref
badge no I understand
okay good work thanks a lot thank you
thank you see you all soon okay bye